>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR.
PRESIDENT.
I AM TRULILY HUMBLED BY THE
EXTRAORDINARY HONOR OF THIS
NOMINATION.
I AM ESPECIALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
CARE YOU HAVE TAKEN IN
DISCHARGING YOUR CONSTITUTIONAL
DUTY IN SERVICE OF OUR DEMOCRACY
WITH ALL THAT IS GOING ON IN THE
WORLD TODAY.
I ALSO OFFER MY SINCERE THANKS
TO YOU, MADAM VICE-PRESIDENT,
FOR YOUR INVALUABLE ROLE IN THIS
NOMINATION PROCESS.
I MUST BEGIN THESE BRIEF REMARKS
BY THANKING GOD FOR DELIVERING
ME TO THIS POINT IF MY
PROFESSIONAL JOURNEY.
MY LIFE HAS BEEN BLESSED BEYOND
MEASURE.
I DO KNOW THAT ONE CAN ONLY COME
THIS FAR BY FAITH.
AMONG MY MANY BLESSINGS AND THE
FIRST IS THE FACT THAT I WAS
BORN IN THIS GREAT COUNTRY.
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA IS
THE GREATEST BEACON OF HOPE AND
DEMOCRACY THE WORLD HAS EVER
KNOWN.
I WAS ALL STAR BLESSED FROM MY
EARLY DAYS TO HAVE A SUPPORTIVE
AND LOVING FAMILY.
MY MOTHER AND FATHER WHO HAVE
BEEN MARRIED FOR 54 YEARS ARE AT
THEIR HOME IN FLORIDA RIGHT NOW.
I KNOW THEY COULD NOT BE MORE
PROUD.
IT WAS MY FATHER WHO STARTED ME
ON THIS PATH WHEN I WAS A CHILD
AS THE PRESIDENT MENTIONED.
MY FATHER MADE THE FAITHFUL
DECISION TO TRANSITION FROM HIS
JOB AS A PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL
HISTORY TEACHER AND GO TO LAW
SCHOOL.
SOME OF MY EARLIEST MEMORIES OF
HIM SITTING AT THE KITCHEN TABLE
READING HIS LAW BOOKS.
I WATCHED HIM STUDY AND HE
BECAME MY FIRST PROFESSIONAL
ROLE MODEL.
MY MOTHER ALWAYS A PUBLIC HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER PROVIDED
INVALUABLE SUPPORT IN THOSE
EARLY DAYS.
WORKING FULL-TIME TO ENABLE MY
FATHER'S CAREER TRANSITION WHILE
ALSO GUIDING AND INSPIRING
4-YEAR-OLD ME.
MY ONLY SIBLING MY BROTHER CAME
ALONG HALF A DECADE LATER.
I AM SO PROUD OF ALL THAT HE
ACCOMPLISHED.
AFTER GRADUATING FROM HOWARD
UNIVERSITY, HE BECAME A POLICE
OFFICER AND A DETECTIVE ON THE
TOUGHEST STREETS IN BALTIMORE.
AFTER THAT HE ENLISTED IN THE
ARMY.
SERVING TWO TOURS OF DUTY IN THE
MIDDLE EAST.
MY UNCLES WERE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
MAO YOU MAY HAVE READ I HAVE ONE
UNCLE WHAT WAS CAUGHT UP IN THE
DRUG TRADE AND RECEIVED A LIFE
SENTENCE.
THAT'S TRUE.
BUT LAW ENFORCEMENT ALSO RUNS IN
MY FAMILY.
I HAD 2 UNCLES WHO SERVED
DECADES AS POLICE OFFICERS AND
ONE BECAME THE POLICE CHIEF IN
MY HOMETOWN IN FLORIDA.
I AM STANDING HERE BECAUSE OF
THE LOVE AND SUPPORT I RECEIVED
FROM MY FAMILY.
I AM BLESSED WITH FRIENDS,
COLLEAGUES AND LAW CLERKS.
I COULD NOT NAME ALL.
PEOPLE TO WHOM I OWE GREAT
THANKS.
I MUST MENTION THE THREE
BRILLANT JURISTS FOR WHOM I
SERVED AS A LAW CLERK AT THE OUT
SET OF MY LEAGUE CAREER.
THE U.S. DIRECT JUDGE PATTY
SERRIS IN MASSACHUSETTS.
U.S. COURT OF APPEALS BRUCE
CELLIA IN RHODE ISLAND AND
STEVEN BREYER OF THE SUPREME
COURT OF THE UNITED STATES.
JUSTICE BREYER NOT ONLY GAVE ME
THE GREATEST JOB THAT ANY YOUNG
LAWYER COULD HOPE TO HAVE BUT
WAS AN EXAMPLE EVERY DAY IN
EVERY WAY THAT A SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE CAN PERFORM AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF SKILL WHILE
BEING GUIDED BY GRACE AND
GENEROSITY OF SPIRIT.
JUSTICE BREYER, THE MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE WILL DECIDE IF I FILL
YOUR SEAT.
BUT PLEASE KNOW THEY COULD NEVER
FILL YOUR SHOES.
TO MY DEAR FAMILY, THOSE WHO ARE
HERE WITH ME NOW AND THOSE WHO
ARE WATCHING FROM HOME, I AM
FOREVER INDEBTED TO YOU FOR YOUR
LOVE AND SUPPORT.
TO MY BELOVED HUSBAND, PATRICK,
THANKS FOR BEING MY ROCK TODAY
AND EVERY DAY FOR THESE PAST 26
YEARS.
I LOVE YOU.
TO MY DAUGHTERS, YOU ARE THE
LIGHT OF MY LIFE.
PLEASE KNOW THAT WHATEVER TITLE
I MAY HOLD OR WHATEVER JOB I MAY
HAVE, I WILL STILL BE YOUR MOM.
THAT WILL NEVER CHANGE.
THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER PEOPLE I
WOULD LOVE TO THANK BUT TIME IS
SHORT.
LET ME END BY SHARING AN
INTERESTING COINCIDENCE IS THAT
MEANT A GREAT DEAL TO ME OVER
THE YEARS.
AS IT HAPPENS, I SHARE
A BIRTHDAY WITH THE FIRST BLACK
WOMAN EVER TO BE APPOINTED AS
A FEDERAL JUDGE.
THE HONORABLE CONSTANCE BAKER
MOCKLEY.
WE WERE BORN 49 YEARS TO THE DAY
APART.
TODAY I PROUDLY STAND ON HER
SHOULDERS SHARING NOT ONLY HER
BIRTHDAY BUT ALSO HER STEADFAST
AND COURAGEOUS COMMITMENT TO
EQUAL JUST UNDER THE LAW.
HER LIFE AND CAREER HAS BEEN AN
ENSPIRATION TO ME.
I PURSUED THIS PROFESSIONAL
PATH.
IF I AM FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE
CONFIRMED AS THE NEXT ASSOCIATE
JUSTICE OF THE U.S. SUPREME
COURT I CAN ONLY HOPE THAT MY
LIFE AND CAREER, MY LOVE OF THIS
COUNTRY AND THE CONSTITUTION AND
MY COMMITMENT TO UPHOLDING THE
RULE OF LAW AND THE SACRED
PRINCIPLES UPON WHICH THIS GREAT
NATION WAS FOUNDED WILL INSPIRE
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF LAWYERS.
THANK YOU, MR., PRESIDENT, FOR
THIS EXTRAORDINARY HONOR.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> I FORGOT TO IT INTRODUCE THE
FIRST LADY JIL